hello everyone and welcome to incredible
game that was played in 2019 in jubar
parka in Johannesburg it was played
between
symphlesia and Levon aronian and it was
sent to me by none other than the
gentleman playing with the white pieces
here yes in Fever sent it to me and he
sent me a video of them actually playing
this game it's a very nice one I will uh
include it in the description below if
you guys want to check it out so uh same
fever at the time this game was played
was rated around 1500 as he uh says in
the email that he sent me and Lavon I
don't know levon's exact uh rating for
Blitz in those days as so I've used his
today's rating but okay you can imagine
it's quite uh quite a quite a difference
more than one thousand rating points uh
so we're gonna check out the game and
then we're gonna even show a little bit
of the actual footage that the two of
them have playing so I said that it's a
Blitz game but it's an odds game uh Sim
fever has three minutes on the clock and
live on has only one minute on the clock
but you know of course he is a a a top
player in the world he's currently like
in Blitz let me just check real quickly
I don't want to trick you guys um but I
think yeah he's definitely in the top 10
uh regarding Blitz uh let me just check
yeah he's currently world number nine in
Blitz I mean so definitely an absolute
Beast so let's check it out uh sympha
has the white pieces and he opens with
C4 he goes for the English opening
Knight to F6 with G3 G6 Knight the C3
and Bishop to G7 uh we have Bishop to G2
Castles by Levon and now Pawn to E4 we
have Pawn to D6 and Knight G2 E2 so all
known Theory nothing new here C5 is the
absolute top move Knight the C6 the the
second most common uh H3 with Ponte E5
and now castles and pawn to A6 and the
position has been reached before it's
been reached in the under under 12 uh
world championship between none other
than uh pental Hare Krishna and Vlad
Christian giano where Hare Krishna won a
very nice game but in that game Ponte F4
was played here we have Pawn to A4 and
it is now as of move nine that we have a
completely new game so okay Knight to
the D7 the Knight is being shifted over
to C5 as the Knight controls B4 so you
don't have to worry about the Knight
getting kicked from there and also you
have uh now the option of uh pushing F5
if needed we have Pawn to F4 bison fever
uh e captures an F for G captures and
now Pawn to F5 striking in the center uh
D3 and now Knights the C5 so okay most
players playing a very nice game if
anyone is to be preferred here will
probably be black a little bit but not
too much uh mostly due to the pawn being
on the three and you are unable to start
advancing those pawns but okay Knight to
D5 with King the h8 both for us just
throwing in a nice prophylactic move as
it's a Blitz game you don't know if it's
needed but you know it might it might
very well be so if captures an E4 D
captures an E4 and now uh reminoving the
Knight over to E7 hoping to trade uh
just Knight E to C3 now you can even
consider capturing with it with the
Knight but most likely you would play C
captures on D5 if the trade happens but
it's not not a bad idea maybe captures
captures and Levon gets the queen into
the game could be very strong but Lavon
first played Pawn to C6 with Knight back
to E3 and Bishop to E6 now just
continuing development with Queen to C2
uh and now Pawn to A5
also uh one of the moves that synthet
could have considered a few moves ago
advancing his own Ponte A5 but okay uh
we have Pawn to F5 now uh he goes for
the attack and what's the idea behind it
well you will see opening up uh of the
black King's position of course G
captures e captures Bishop to G8 and now
even Pawn to F6 not allowing levona
moment's uh rest uh as uh he he is
playing with a minute on the clock so
you really want to make him defend uh
Bishop captures even Rook captures an F6
so Rook captures and now Knight the G4
and now of course the idea is you want
to move this Knight and you want to play
Queen to C3 check and how is Levant to
defend against this also Bishop H6 is
cut is coming uh will be very hard to
defend we have rooked the G6 and now
comes the bishop to H6 and incredible as
it is uh there is only one move that of
course you know that one's position is
better why just sacrifice for the attack
but you have to be extremely precise
here so feel feel free to pause the
video and try to find the only move that
will wins the game but you have to be
very precise for Levon while I give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on making sense of
this whole mess of a position and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Bishop to E6 this is the only
move for black that
um uh that makes sense because you are
already threatening to remove the
defender of the bishop on H6 so that's
the threat you have to react to this
Knight the E4 white will just continue
with his plan of course he wants to play
Queen to C3 check and uh well just end
the game so for the moment you cannot
capture on G4 if you do this then Queen
to C3 check King to Jade and now Knight
to F6 check you have to capture here
captures captures uh and okay uh black
isn't lost or anything but uh you you
will not be uh winning this game anymore
after Knight to F5 you you defend
against Checkmate you over a queen trade
everything is perfectly fine so what you
would have to do after Knight to E4 is
just go Knight to F5 just put more
pressure on the bishop and now okay
Queen to C3 check you're gonna play King
to G8 but now you have to do something
for example Rook to G1 if everything
thing moves away from the G file you can
threaten some discoveries but now you
can pretty much choose what you want you
can play nice captures and A4 you can
play Queen to H6 you know the the sky is
the limit but you are winning this game
however uh it's a Blitz game live on
started with one minute on the clock he
of course does not find Bishop to E6 he
played Knight to C8 and now we have
Queen to D2 going for that Queen to D4
Square so Queen to H4 saying okay you
give your uh check doesn't really do
anything but the problem is it it does
do a lot Queen to D4 check was played we
have Rook to F6 there's no other way to
defend uh now comes Queen captures on F6
Queen captures and Knight captures and
now uh yeah you don't really have a way
of saving your king the Knight controls
the G8 Square the bishop controls the G7
square and you're also down material so
Bishop captures on C4 Lavon grabs this
Pawn but now Rook to E1 threatening Rook
to E8 Checkmate Levon of course prevents
this Knight to B6 and Here Comes Rook
the E7 and now there is no defense
against Bishop to G7 Checkmate if you go
Rook to G then Rook captures an H7 is of
course Checkmate LeBron played Bishop to
D3 to stop this Checkmate but now this
is met with of course Bishop to G7
Checkmate so uh incredible stuff uh
simply with the lazy defeats uh Levon
arunyan who is I mean an absolute Legend
so big congratulations to him and even
though uh the game was was played quite
a few years ago it has only a couple of
views on YouTube so do check out the
video here I'm just gonna play a little
uh bit of the video for you just for you
to feel the atmosphere of the you know
the moment the celebration of the moment
and I love in the video that Sim
fifiable lazy just defeated levonne
Arena one of the greatest players in the
world in any time format and the The
Spectators are just telling he that he
is the greatest player in the park so I
mean that's a pretty crazy stuff and
also yeah I've checked uh he gave me his
Alicia's handle I've actually played two
games against butalezi unleasha so we
played one bullet game and won three
minute Blitz game I've lost both of them
so uh you know uh
uh very very nicely done by him uh but
yeah here and yeah and also if you guys
want to challenge him his uh handle on
leeches is seems that 19 I will put it
in the description below that will be
the second thing like after the link uh
to the YouTube video will be his leeches
handle so you can challenge him if you
guys want basically if he defeated Levon
and you defeat him uh well I don't have
to tell you what that means I mean it's
a pretty much self-explanatory but let's
check out the celebration video there
you have it
okay
this is my boy I told you I paid for
this West flight I paid for this voice
[Applause]
[Music]
what you're gonna do the best player in
the park I and also I really love
levon's hat in the Hat in that video
really looks like he's having the you
know the the time of his life uh but
yeah like I said if you wanna if you
wanna challenge seems that I will be a
link in the description below and also
do check out the full video of them
playing it's a it's been uploaded a
couple of years ago it has only a couple
of views so if you want to congratulate
him on that video as well uh you know it
will it would be the honorable thing to
do uh so yeah that's the game really
hope you guys enjoyed it uh uh a big
thanks to uh Sim fever with lazy for
sending me this game and you know uh you
you never know when you you guys will
get a chance to play against the player
like LaVon and you might even win a game
if you do be sure to send me uh the PGN
and I will very very gladly show that
game so once again really hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Ricky
Johnson
Derek King Alexandria darola uh and Dean
bodenham for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing uh to check up um and
everything that's happening in the Chess
World and also on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day